The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
TADGE DRYJA: OK, so today I will
talk about mostly fees, which
is an interesting and
somewhat contentious
issue in Bitcoin and
all these other systems.
So schedule for today,
problem set 3 description,
we'll talk about fees,
these unknowable acronyms--
Child Pays for Parent,
Replaced By Fee--
and then talk a little bit
about long-term incentives
in Bitcoin, and how
that relates to fees.
OK, so the problem set
3 is to grab UTXOs.
Hopefully it's fun.
You're going to be
making transactions
on the real Bitcoin
test network.
So one of the parts of it
that hopefully is not too hard
is downloading and install
Bitcoin D. So I'll put a link.
The current, most up-to-date
version is 0.16.0.
I believe the next
version will just
be called 17, because a lot
of the developers are like,
this is annoying, it's
always starting with a zero,
it's like 0.1, 0.2, 0.3.
And they're like,
well, at some point,
should we get to version 1?
And they're like,
well, everyone's
going to think version
1 means it's better.
Let's just call the next
version 17 instead of 0.17.
So download that, and
then sync up to testnet.
If you just run
it by default, it
will sync up to the main
network, which will download
something like 170 gigabytes.
You don't want that.
And the homework assignment
cannot be completed on the main
network.
There's no free money--
I haven't put any free
money on the main network.
However, on the test
network, it'll work.
And it's about 11
gigabytes of download.
So I think most
people, on your laptop,
probably have 11 gigs free.
It's doable.
And it's kind of fun
to see how it works.
So if you don't have
access to 11 gigs,
you can probably get an
Athena node to do it.
It's not too big.
You can run a tiny little
node with not much RAM, not
much space, and it'll work.
You can also sync up
on a Raspberry Pi.
It just takes a little longer.
So I don't think it'll
be too hard to do.
You can probably get around--
sort of the goal
of the assignment
is to check out the actual
Bitcoin D and Bitcoin CLI.
You can use a block
explorer if you want.
I'm not going to
say that's cheating,
but it's also not as fun.
So the block explorers
websites will
help you find a lot of
things, because they
have different databases
and different indexes
so you can sort of
search through things.
It's more fun if you
write it yourself.
But if you try this,
OK, that works too.
Yeah, so hopefully you get
familiar with the Bitcoin CLI.
If you want to do your own
scripting with Bitcoin,
you can use anything you want.
So Bitcoin CLI is a
command-line utility
that will let you interact
with the Bitcoin node.
So for example--
is this readable?
Kind of, right?
So if I want to get peer info.
I want to see-- this
is a computer down
on the first floor,
running Bitcoin Mainnet,
I want to see, OK,
who's connected to me?
And then it'll tell me.
It returns JSON, and it
tells me all about the people
I'm connected to.
If I want to say, get
wallet info, it'll tell me
I don't have any money--
things like that.
And then there's, like, Help.
It's weird and it's not
super well documented.
It's fairly well
documented in this stuff.
There's also tons of
undocumented hidden RPC calls
that are deprecated, or
new, or programmers put in
and they don't want
people to use them.
They only want to use
them for themselves.
So it's kind of a
mess, but it's fun
to see exactly how
this software works.
So hopefully you
can try that out.
And I will add more UTXOs to
grab in the next few days.
So that might be fun.
You could, if you wanted to be a
jerk, just steal all the money,
and then no one
else could do it.
But please don't do that.
I mean, this is not as
adversarial a setting
as actual Bitcoin.
If someone does it,
I'll be like, OK, fine,
and I'll just like
reseed the place.
So hopefully we don't
have too many trolls
trying to prevent
everyone from having fun
with this assignment.
That said, there is at--
aspect some of them are--
the one I put in the
assignment last night,
there's five outputs
that you can grab.
One of the sort of hints--
there's only five outputs.
So the first five people
to grab it get the coins.
So there is a little bit
of timing stuff there.
Any questions?
Cool?
Yeah, so if you have
questions about it,
office hours tomorrow,
also IRC, stuff like that.
OK, so today's main topic--
transaction fees.
So we described earlier that
the transaction fee is just
the difference between the sum
of the input amounts and output
amounts.
What's interesting
is it's implicit.
So if you actually
look at a transaction,
you can't tell
what the fees are.
You have to look
at its ancestors
to tell what the fees are.
So for example, if you want
to go through here and-- oh,
how am I going to do this?
Jeez.
If I want to say, OK, what's
the most current block?
getblockchaininfo.
OK, so the most
current block is this.
And then I can
say, OK, getblock--
can I just say getblock?
Yeah, I want to get that block.
OK, there's all the
transactions in this block.
I can do getblock verbose
true, and it'll give me
all the transaction data.
But instead, I can just pick
one of these transactions
and say getrawtransaction,
get that thing.
Oh, here's another weird thing.
So it'll just give
you hex, which
is not very useful, unless you
somehow can read hexadecimal.
And then in the actual thing,
it says, like, examples.
Wait, true?
Did they change it?
You used to have
to do 1 at the end.
Yeah.
But true works too?
It used to not work
if you said true,
and you had to put the
number 1 instead of true.
There is a lot of
weird bugs in Bitcoin
that have been there
for years, and I
guess they fixed that one.
The most egregious is
probably the multisig bug,
where when you're spending
from a multisig output,
you have to push a zero-byte
onto the stack first,
or else it doesn't work.
It was just a bug Satoshi had.
And now it's consensus critical.
And people joke about
it, like, oh, we also
have to put a zero-byte
in whatever new
RPC we create, because
there's just, like, bugs.
Anyway, so for example, this
transaction that I just brought
up, this is how it'll look.
Here's the TXID,
it's 370 bytes, it's
got this lock time, which--
ooh, I should mention that.
I'm guessing this transaction
was created by Bitcoin Core
Wallet, not a different wallet.
That's a hint.
It's got one input--
no, two inputs.
OK, so inputs are
specified-- this TXID input,
this TXID input--
two inputs and one
output of value, 0004500.
We can't tell what
the fee is from this.
No, sorry, two outputs.
Here are the two outputs.
So we can tell these
two outputs, however,
we don't know what the fees are.
We know the total
output amounts,
but the input amounts
are not encoded
in the transaction itself.
In order to figure
that out, we'd
have to go to this transaction
and see what vout 0's output
amount is, which we can do.
And it's 0052-- you know, so
we can add it up that way,
but it's not written directly,
which is a little weird.
And the idea of the
fee is, whoever mines
that block that includes that
transaction gets the fee.
So the sum of all the inputs
and outputs within a block
do add up, modulo the new
coins that are created.
But long-term, when there's
no coins being created,
when they've all been
created, you can say,
OK, we can look
at a block, add up
all the inputs spent in all
the transactions in the block,
add up all the outputs created
in all the transactions
in the block, and
those should equal.
Otherwise, it's invalid.
Well, they don't have to equal.
You're always allowed
to destroy coins.
So if the miner
says, hey, there's
all these fees that
can be paid to me,
and I just don't grab
them, you can do that.
So it's a less-than-or-equals
operator that-- it's the check.
And people have destroyed
coins, usually inadvertently.
There was one in
January where there
was a block that just had a zero
output for the miner reward,
so all whatever, 13, 14
coins were just destroyed.
Yeah, it seemed like a bug.
So that's how fees work.
What's interesting is,
you don't know who you're
paying when you create the fee.
You sign sort of, OK,
here's my transaction,
I sign it off, whoever confirms
this transaction gets $5
or whatever.
And you throw it out there.
So it's kind of interesting.
There could be legal--
I've heard there's legal
questions, like, well, what
if one of the miners
is in Iran, now
you're paying someone in Iran,
are you in trouble for that?
You don't know.
You can't tell who going
to mine it beforehand.
And generally, we talk
about fee rates, or sort
of a specific fee-per-byte.
And it's expressed in Satoshis
per byte, and one Satoshi
being the minimum
possible bitcoin
amount, which is 1, 2, 3, 4,
1, 2, 3 zeros, so seven years.
There's eight digits in bitcoin.
And you usually keep that.
So you pad it out.
So even in something
where it's 0.0134,
they put the extra four zeros.
In the actual code, this is
just a 64-bit signed integer,
and there is no decimal point.
So it's sort of a UI thing
to put a decimal point in so
that people can think of,
oh, that's two bitcoins,
or that's half a bitcoin.
But really, the code only
deals with the Satoshis,
and the decimal point
is purely UI layer,
which can be
confusing sometimes,
when you're dealing
with JSON, and when
you're dealing with
different programs,
tossing numbers around.
You can get a factor of
100 million off, sometimes.
It's a big enough factor that,
usually, it's pretty obvious.
So from a miner's
point of view, they
want to prioritize, based on
the TX size and the fee rate
because space is limited.
So one of the other
rules that's probably
one of the most controversial
and argued-about rules
in Bitcoin was a 1-megabyte
block size limit.
So the idea is, OK, you can
put all these transactions
in the block, but the total
block, when serialized,
including the headers
and everything,
needs to be 1 million
bytes or less,
which is now not quite
true because there's
ways around that.
But there's still a hard
limit of 4 megabytes today.
What's also interesting is it's
totally unrelated to the amount
of coins being transferred.
So in that sense,
the fee is flat.
Whether you're sending 100
Bitcoins, or one Bitcoin,
or a millionth of a Bitcoin.
The miner doesn't really care.
It's just based on space.
You're paying for your
data usage of the network,
and your actual sort of
monetary value transferring
is unrelated to that.
To some extent, later on,
you might think, well,
miners might try to charge
people sending more money
more because they're
more able to pay.
But so far, we haven't
seen anything like that.
It's mostly just the
miners looking at,
I've got a megabyte of size
to parcel out to people,
I'm going to try to pack that in
is at as high a rate as I can.
And whether someone's paying
a little bit or a lot--
whether someone is moving
a little bit or a lot,
the miners don't care.
Any questions
about these things?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about actually the miners
getting the fees.
So how does that--
because that's not part of
the Coinbase transaction.
TADGE DRYJA: It is, it is.
So if we look--
how am I going to do this?
AUDIENCE: You could look
into the Coinbase transaction
in the block and find out
what the fees would be.
TADGE DRYJA: Well, if you
assume that the block is valid.
So OK, the first
transaction is always
the Coinbase transaction.
That's little.
So I'm going to do
getrawtransaction,
get this one.
And yeah, it says, Coinbase.
So Coinbase's arbitrary data,
you've got a sequence number,
there is no witness here--
or is-- OK, anyway.
Yeah, there is witness.
OK, so this block is--
well, two blocks have
come out since I first
looked at it, because there's
now two confirmations.
This is SegWit-related,
which I think
I'm going to talk about Monday.
So that's sort of this
weird opportune thing.
This is the actual
Coinbase payout
that the miner is
getting, and it's 12.79.
So he got almost 0.4 extra
coins in fees, which is what,
like $4,000, pretty good.
It was super high
a few months ago.
So it all gets aggregated.
12.5 comes out of nowhere.
12.5 is the new coins
being generated.
And then the 0.398 is the sum
of all the fees in that block.
AUDIENCE: I guess you
don't know [INAUDIBLE]
TADGE DRYJA: Well, you have to
look at all the transactions.
So if you look at
a transaction, it
doesn't say in the
transaction itself.
You have to look
at a transaction,
look up its inputs, see
the sum of all the inputs,
and then subtract
and say, OK, I can
calculate the fee
for this transaction,
calculate the fee for all
these different transactions,
add it all up, it should equal--
and it does exactly
equal 0.398 da da da da.
So for the computer,
it's pretty quick.
But yeah, it is a little
bit weird accounting
to try to add it
all up yourself.
Any other questions about
fee stuff, about this?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Do miners
choose what blocks to mine
based on their [INAUDIBLE]?
TADGE DRYJA: Yes, but I'm
not sure I'd put it that way.
The miners construct
the block to mine.
So in the case of--
here, getblock head dash 30, I
don't want to show all of the--
but this is, OK, the
miner mined this block.
Here's the size, weight,
height, version, vertical route.
All these transactions
that get included
are produced by the miner.
So the miner sort of aggregates
the transactions themselves,
and then decides to mine.
So I think I talk about
that in the next--
wait, do I say that?
Yeah, OK.
I'll talk about that
in the next slide.
So basically the fee rate is
set by the transaction signer.
When you're creating
a transaction--
OK, I want to sign one Bitcoin,
I will spend 500 Satoshis,
my transaction is
about 250 bytes, OK,
that's a two-Satoshis-per-byte
fee rate.
You choose your fee rate, sign--
the way you increment and
decrement your fee rate is
to say, OK, I've got
some change output,
I'm going to increase or
decrease the change output
amount.
If someone's saying,
hey, pay me one coin,
I can't really
change their amount
and say, like, oh, sorry
man, there was a high fee,
you didn't get a bitcoin.
And that's sort of a cultural--
that's not a software thing.
If someone says, pay me a
coin, you need to pay the coin.
It's generally the sender
who's covering the fee.
Which is different than
in credit cards, right?
In credit cards, it says
$10, I swipe my card,
I get charged $10,
and the merchant
is the one absorbing the fee.
And I don't even
know what the fee is.
There's actually
contractual law that I'm not
allowed to hear what the fee
is, the merchant can't tell me,
things like that.
But in general, in Bitcoin,
this fee is set by the sender.
The transactions, however,
are chosen by the miners.
So the idea is, you create
your transaction, set your fee,
throw it out there,
everyone sort of broadcasts
it to everyone else.
And the miner then
looks at all these fees,
looks at all these transactions,
and chooses the best ones.
It's essentially
an auction process
where you're bidding for us for
space in a future block that
has not yet been created.
So the simplest miner-side
algorithm is, take the mempool,
sort the mempool transactions
by their fee rate,
choose the top megabyte,
put them all in order,
compute a merkle route from
all those transaction IDs,
and then mine it.
So the-- yeah, I explained
the merkle route stuff, right?
So you're going to pick
a couple thousand--
5,000, maybe-- transactions,
sort them by fee rate,
put them all in a row,
hash it a bunch of times,
and then just that 80-byte
header you keep mining.
However, this keeps changing.
This mempool changes
every second.
There's new transactions coming
up multiple times a second.
And so you're going to
re-compute that every second,
probably, and say, oh, this
new transaction came out,
oh, the fee's really
low, ignore it,
that doesn't meet my threshold.
Versus, new transaction
comes out, oh, it's
got a really high fee rate,
OK, put it in near the top,
and push out one or two
transactions at the bottom.
And now I'm mining a block that
will have slightly higher fees.
So this is sort of a
real-time process, where
this is constantly changing.
The mining is even
faster, so you're
going to mine trillions
and trillions of attempts
for each specific merkle route.
But the merkle routes are also
going to change multiple times
a second.
The nonce is going to change
a gazillion times a second.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: How do you
know that you're not
mining a stale transaction?
TADGE DRYJA: So you know
it's in the mempool,
you know it hasn't been--
well, you don't
know, you're pretty
sure that it has not been
confirmed in a block already.
But it may be the case
that someone just came out
with a block a few seconds
ago, and you haven't seen it,
and then you are mining
a stale transaction.
The thing is, whether
the transaction is stale
or not, even if you
mine a block and it's
got a completely different
set of transactions
than the block you were
unaware of, you still lose out.
Because you're pointing--
so OK, this comes out,
but you're not aware of
it yet, and you mine this.
Even if they have a completely
disjoint set of transactions,
it doesn't matter because
they're still pointing
to the same parent block.
So you still, now, have two
blocks of the same height.
You might win.
If this happens, hey, maybe
this one gets built upon.
Generally, miners pick the first
seen block to build off of.
But you could change that.
And you can't really verify
that that's the case.
So yeah, it is
possible that you're
mining transactions
that have already
been included in the block
that you're not aware.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Because blocks are
changing all the time based
on the transactions
you want to put in it,
are you kind of mining different
blocks at the same time?
So the first one, you
try-- have started mining,
do you keep mining
that one or no?
TADGE DRYJA: You could.
So in practice, probably yes,
but on a very small timescale.
So what you'll have is we'll get
block template, you'll have--
it's like network latency.
So you'll have, let's say, a
bunch of different warehouses
that all have thousands and
thousands of these mining
chips.
And they will connect
in, and they'll
pull every second or so, and
get the current transaction
list to mine.
And that'll get
updated every second.
And so there may be sort of lags
between different warehouses,
between different machines,
that are mining slightly
different sets of transactions.
But generally, they're
going to be synchronized.
Over the same time
scale of a few seconds,
they're all going
to be synchronized.
They're going to be
updated pretty quickly.
Because every time a new
transaction comes in,
that's potentially more
fees that you can get.
So you want to push
that out and update it.
Let's say a transaction comes
in that's got a nice $5.00 fee,
and you can push out some
$4.00 fee transactions,
that's an extra buck.
And if you don't get it in
time, and mine a block anyway,
hey, you still mined a buck,
but that $5 fee transaction now
goes to the next person
mining the block.
So you want to minimize your
latency so that you get things
as quickly as possible.
But there will be some skew.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: How does
mining stale transactions
affect the block order and
block transaction fees?
TADGE DRYJA: Sorry,
mining what transactions?
AUDIENCE: Stale transactions.
TADGE DRYJA: If you have--
wait, wait.
OK, wait.
Stale transactions?
A transaction that's
already been in a block?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
TADGE DRYJA: It just
invalidates the whole thing.
If you have if you
have a transaction here
that was already confirmed
here, this block is invalid,
and no one will--
they'll just drop it.
So stale transaction
isn't really a term.
It's a stale block.
This is a stale block because,
well, someone made it,
but it got orphaned out,
and no one's using it.
AUDIENCE: So the answer is,
there's no reward for that,
right?
TADGE DRYJA: Worse.
You lose all your--
you lose everything.
So if there's
transaction A in here,
and you try to include
the block itself
is invalid, even
if it has valid proof of work.
So you lose everything.
The thing is, in practice,
it's not a problem.
Because you're
pointing to this block,
so you must have
already seen it.
So it's really easy to just
say, well, don't include any
of the transactions in here.
OK, wait, sometimes it's
a little complicated.
Sometimes you see
this block, and then
you immediately want to start
mining the block on top of it.
But it's a fraction of a
second, and you haven't actually
validated it.
And you don't even
know what's in it.
Maybe you only have
the 80-byte header.
So one optimization which
is sort of bad in a way
but optimal for the
miners is build a block
that's empty on top of it.
You haven't even seen what
transactions are in this block.
You don't even
know if it's valid.
But it's probably valid,
because most blocks are.
And so what you do is you build
on top of it, you point to it,
but since you don't know
what transactions are in it,
the safest thing is just to
include no transactions in your
so there's no overlap.
And you only do this for
a fraction of a second
until you've figured out
the Transaction List here
and subtracted all the--
removed all those from your set.
But it saves you maybe 1/10 of
a second, 1/20, whatever it is.
Which, over time,
statistically, you
could be mining in
that 1/10 of a second.
You don't you want
your chips to not
be doing anything productive
for those fractions of a second.
So that does happen.
That is not software that's
in the normal Bitcoin D,
but miners have written their
own software to do that.
And so you will occasionally
see completely empty blocks
with just a Coinbase
transaction.
And they're almost always very
soon after the previous block,
where you see one that
comes out at 10:30
and 27 seconds, 10:30 and
29 seconds, and it's empty.
So that does happen,
and that can work.
Although what was
it, two years ago
that happened,
where a miner mined
a blocked that was invalid.
Another miner
mined a block here,
very quickly, that was empty.
And then a bunch of miners
started building off of it
because they're like,
well, this one looks valid,
there's no transactions in it.
And they mined like six
or seven blocks in a row,
and the whole thing
was just invalid.
Because they figured, the stuff
I'm building off of must be OK.
So they lost some money there.
This makes sense, right?
Sort the mempool by fee rate,
choose the top megabyte,
compute a merkle route, mine.
Why is it not this simple?
And I mean on an
algorithmic way.
If you're just like, yeah,
sort, choose fee rate,
sort, quick-sort
or whatever, that's
super quick, and then mine.
Why is it actually,
complexity-wise, not--
what is it, n log
n for quick-sort?
It's definitely not n
log n for the optimal.
Although, wait, quick-sort is
worst-case scenario n-squared
[INAUDIBLE] right?
No, it's way worse
than n-squared.
Anyway, any guesses onto why
the algorithmic complexity
is actually quite a bit worse?
AUDIENCE: Is it because the
example keeps on changing?
TADGE DRYJA: No, I'm
saying, even at any--
yeah, that changes it over time.
But at any one state, let's
say, here's a mempool,
find the optimal transaction
set to put into your block.
AUDIENCE: Because Bitcoin
is slow to search,
so you have to go into each
transaction and find the fee?
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah, but
that's still n log n, right?
Yeah, just because
the look-up is slower,
that doesn't change the O.
AUDIENCE: The problem is
[INAUDIBLE] because you
have to find [INAUDIBLE].
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah, so
there's dependencies.
So the thing is, there may be
a transaction-- you can't just
take all these transactions
independently and sort them.
There may be a transaction
with a very high fee
rate which depends on a
transaction with a very low fee
rate.
And so you know it's spending
an output that hasn't yet
been created.
So now it becomes--
it's NP-hard.
In practice, the
heuristics are fine.
But it is pretty
ugly in that you're
like, well, this transaction
has a very low fee,
I'm not going to include it.
This transaction that depends
on it has a high fee rate.
Now I have to take the sort
of mean of the two fee rates,
and keep computing those things.
So it can get quite complex.
In practice, it's usually OK.
You have some heuristics
in the code that
sort of don't deal with that.
Also, I think you have max--
there's no hard rule, but the
algorithms that mine usually
have a max depth of like
three or four transactions,
where they say, look, if
there's a chain of like four
dependent transactions,
I'm not going
to keep going down that path.
Because you could potentially
have enormous chains,
where you have 100 transactions,
each depending on another.
And then the one at the very
end has a very high fee rate,
and you're going to have
to go through all this.
So they limit their search
to like four or something
like that.
Oh, sorry.
Yeah, so the TX dependencies
make it kind of hard.
Cheap transaction which allows
an expensive transaction
to be confirmed, we call
this Child Pays for Parent,
in that you've got this--
in a graph, you've
a child transaction,
and it's essentially paying
for the parent transaction
by having a higher fee.
There is no Parent
Pays for Child,
in that if you've got a
transaction with a high fee
rate, and then a descendant
transaction with a low fee
rate, you just take the
parent and you ignore
the child and someone
else in a later block
can grab that child transaction.
However, the
dependency graph is,
no, if you want
in on this child,
the parent has to
be confirmed first.
It actually has to be confirmed
earlier in the list of TXIDs
in the block.
So it's not-- so like in this,
when you look at a block,
the transactions are sequenced.
And this transaction can
spend that transaction.
But you need to be able
to go in through linearly.
Update your UTXO set
at every row here,
and it should be consistent.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
TADGE DRYJA: Yes.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned LVIV,
those are [INAUDIBLE] terms.
You mentioned a
threshold earlier.
How is that
threshold determined?
TADGE DRYJA: Oh, OK, so there
isn't really a threshold.
It's just at any point, you're
looking, and you're like,
well, my minimum fee here
is 30 Satoshis per byte.
Given the block I'm trying to
mine, what's my lowest fee?
OK, 30 Satoshis per byte.
So if I see one
with less than that,
I know right away
I can ignore it.
But yeah, it keeps
changing every time
a new transaction comes in
that displaces an old one, now
your minimum fee changes.
So that's just sort of
an easy way to look.
There is also a relay threshold
which I believe most nodes now
have at one Satoshi per byte,
where if you're not mining
and someone gives you a
transaction which is less than
one-Satoshi-per-byte fee rate,
you will ignore it and not pass
it on to your peers.
That's sort of an
anti-spam kind of thing.
And it may be too high.
It's also not a
consensus rule, and you
can set it to whatever you
want in your config file.
And nodes won't get mad at you.
They won't ban you if
you send something low.
So that's sort of
from the miner's side.
From the miner's
point of view, you
keep seeing all these
transactions, you sort them,
you have to deal with the sort
of descendent transactions.
But you try to get a good
block, try to mine it.
And you don't really care
what people are doing,
you just want to
make a lot of money.
You just want to
maximize for fees.
From the person
transacting, on their side,
you want to minimize fees.
You don't want to
pay these miners.
They already make
gazillions of dollars
anyway from all the
new bitcoins they're
generating-- bunch of jerks.
So you set your fee to
one Satoshi per byte.
So you know it'll be relayed,
you sign it, and you broadcast.
Easy, right?
So what's the problem here?
Nobody--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
TADGE DRYJA: Doesn't confirm,
all the miners ignore it.
This is actually a huge--
well, OK, no, probably
the biggest sort
of UI problem in
Bitcoin is that people
have, for years
and years, lost all
of their coins due to
theft, or loss, or whatever.
That's the big one.
But other than that, this
is the biggest UI problem.
This is the biggest problem
in Bitcoin for users.
I made a transaction, it hasn't
confirmed, what the heck?
And I sort of had, on
Reddit, BTC fees, WTF.
[CHUCKLING]
Like, why are BTC fees so high?
There's constant people
complaining, what the heck,
why--
are you kidding me?
Trezor says $50 in fees.
Am I missing something?
People get mad.
And then there's also, I
made a transaction last week,
it hasn't confirmed.
Bitcoin doesn't work.
Bitcoin sucks.
I hate this thing.
So huge UI problem, really
poor user experience.
A lot of it is, also,
the software is bad.
Wallets-- OK, a
couple of years ago,
wallets would always
just set a zero fee.
There weren't fees in 2012.
You just didn't pay any--
2013, right?
I never paid fees.
It was awesome.
Because there was this
block-size limit of one
megabyte.
But no one was ever running
up against that limit.
The miners would just
say, look, I'm not even
going to sort anything
because there's
200 kilobytes worth of
transactions in the mempool.
I just mine all of them,
whether the fees are zero,
whether the fees are one
Satoshi, whatever-- whatever
I can get, just mine it all.
Now you've got this
constrained space,
and so you're optimizing--
the miner is.
But years ago, you weren't.
And so the wallets,
a lot of times,
they would either have
zero fee, completely,
a fixed fee per
transaction, which
is also really
suboptimal-- they just
say, OK, I'll pay 100 hundreds
Satoshi per transaction.
Some transactions have a lot
of inputs, are much bigger,
so that's a highly
variable fee rate which
the user can't control.
Or they'd have a fixed fee
rate, where they just say,
I'm going to set five
Satoshis per byte,
and that's the fee
rate in this wallet,
and you don't allow the
user to change it at all.
That's also really suboptimal.
Once the fee market
starts changing
and people start paying
more, this wallet software
will not work.
Or you can have the user choose
a fee rate, which seems great,
but users are
like, I don't know.
You're using Bitcoin,
what fee rate do you want,
10 Satoshis per
byte, 20, 40, 70?
What's a Satoshi?
What's a byte?
This is not a great problem
to hand off to the user.
How do I even determine this?
There are sites, and the sites
aren't very good, either.
Where was it-- yeah, here
is what used to be 21.co,
with all the Raspberry Pi guys.
And then this is
their fee rate thing,
which is a really
hard-to-understand chart.
What does this mean, unconfirmed
transactions, transactions
today?
What are these numbers?
I still don't really
understand this site.
And at the bottom it
says, fastest and cheapest
transaction fee is
50 Satoshis per byte,
shown in green at the top.
So I guess this, or this.
Thing is, huge overestimate.
I think one Satoshi per
byte is probably OK today--
maybe five.
This is a better
site-- also complex--
where you can say,
OK, well, here's
the mempool size in
megabytes, sorted by fee rate.
And you can see that,
well, at 8 o'clock,
mempool was basically empty.
At 8 o'clock, you
could have paid zero
and it would have
gotten through,
but people are paying more now.
And it's also kind of crazy to
see that some people are paying
200 Satoshis per byte,
even though, generally,
over the course of a few
hours, zero Satoshis per byte
will also confirm.
Are they really time-sensitive?
Probably not.
Probably, their
software is crummy,
and their software
just estimates 200.
So it's easy to
make fun of people
and be like, these
guys are idiots.
It's actually not that easy to
estimate what fee you should
issue a transaction with.
It's also sort of asymmetric
in that a lot of exchanges,
someone says, I want to
withdraw my 10 bitcoins.
I traded, this is a lot
of money, withdraw, click.
It doesn't confirm
for six hours.
The customer gets
super mad and starts
calling customer support.
Whereas if the
exchange is like, look,
we're just going to issue
all of our transactions
with 200 Satoshis
per byte, they always
go through the next block.
Yeah, we lose money.
But maybe we get the
customer to pay for it.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Do you
think it could be
people using maybe percentage
of their transactions,
which obviously doesn't
make any sense, but--
TADGE DRYJA: I
don't think there's
any software that does that
AUDIENCE: --finance
firm, and that's
just what they're used to.
That's how they're used to
paying fees, [INAUDIBLE]..
I don't think so.
TADGE DRYJA: I've never seen
any software that does that.
I've seen some software
that does really dumb stuff
with regard to fees.
I haven't seen that.
That would be a new thing.
So I don't think so, but maybe.
AUDIENCE: I presume that
it's the exchanges or wallet,
companies just feel like their
customers are happy are happier
and they're charging
their customers.
It's just passing through
the cost to customers.
But a quick question--
why not just
do an algorithm that takes
the last six to 10 blocks,
maybe time-weights it, and
do an algorithm base, so
an actual experience
in the marketplace?
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah, that is
what the current Bitcoin D
algorithm does.
Even that can be off sometimes.
And it allows sort
of a estimate--
OK, how quickly
do you need this?
Do you need this
in the next hour,
do you need it in the next
six hours, the next half hour?
So yeah, the one in
Bitcoin D is better.
But it's not-- it's easy to
say, oh, this should be easy.
The thing is, it's
a weird market.
You're bidding for something
that you don't quite know--
and you don't know what
other participants are
going to pile in.
Sometimes-- so something
like this, oh, a block
didn't come out
for half an hour,
and a bunch of other people
came and submitted higher bids
after you.
And so now you got out--
in practice, well, yeah,
someone who submitted a bid
here, a transaction here,
a block came out there, and--
let's zoom in for an example.
Well, that's too low.
But I submitted something here.
I think it will get in.
But then all these other
people came after me,
and then the block
didn't confirm mine.
It did later, another
few minutes later.
But it's hard-- there's
never any determinism in how
it's going to work.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So if fees
are always lower
around 8:00 AM or 4:00 AM,
why not just pool transactions
for around that time?
TADGE DRYJA: They're
not, because it's
all over the world.
They do tend to be
lower on the weekends.
People don't make as many
transactions on the weekends.
And so, yes, sometimes
people will say,
hey, I've got
these transactions.
In practice, if you say, I
don't care how long it takes,
just set a low fee and wait.
And it will stay in
the mempool for weeks.
So there have been people who
said, I made a transaction,
I put a super-low fee, it
confirmed a month later.
The thing is, if you--
I should go, yeah, this
is something of a tangent.
But if you look over six months,
it's really highly variable.
It used to be sort of
nothing, and then--
part of it is the--
it looks most dramatic here,
because you're sorting by--
this shows the fee rate.
It's like nothing.
You don't have to deal with it.
And then like, whoa, OK.
And people were
complaining, hey,
it's days where
nothing confirmed.
Here it was weeks, months, like
all of December and January.
And it was correlated
with everyone
in the media, everyone
wanting to buy bitcoins,
the price skyrocketed.
So it's very sort of peaky.
And then I think interest
has died down a bit,
and the fees have
gone down with it.
So this is a hard
problem to deal with.
And it wasn't something
people were dealing
with until a few months ago.
Most of the time, you could
get by with just setting
a low fixed fee or
something, and it would work.
But now we're really seeing
the fee market develop.
Also, people disagreed that
this should even be a thing.
So there's Bitcoin Cash,
there's all these forks,
the idea of, if you start
hitting the block-size limit,
increase the limit.
Why should we have to pay fees?
The miners are already getting
plenty of money to mine with,
we should just have as much
transactions that we want.
So there's people that say that.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, if you're
not getting them confirmed,
you could just issue another
transaction with higher fees.
TADGE DRYJA: That's what
I'm going to get to next.
So not always.
So one, your software
might not do that.
Most software in
the last few years
just said, look, once
the transaction is sent,
it's stuck.
It's just like, yeah, I sent
it, waiting for it to confirm.
And you have to
actually code something
to deal with changing
the transaction ID,
invalidating the old one.
That's some software.
So one way a wallet could
deal with this is to say,
OK, well I'll do
Child Pays for Parent.
This is actually a little
bit easier, software-wise,
because you don't have
to invalidate anything.
You could just say, I'm going
to send a transaction, spending
one of those new outputs
that's not confirmed,
with a very high fee.
Now, the average of the
two will be high enough,
maybe it will get in.
You can also do this when
you're on the receiving end.
So if someone sent you a coin,
but they sent that transaction
with a low fee.
And maybe you can't
contact them anymore,
maybe they're unresponsive
or they don't care.
And you're like, well, I
really need this money,
I want it confirmed,
I can then respend
that output with a high fee
to confirm both of them.
It's kind of annoying,
but possible.
Downsides of this--
Child Pays for Parent
is very inefficient.
You're making an
extra transaction.
And it's exacerbating the
problem you're trying to solve.
The whole problem is, there's
too many transactions,
there's not enough space.
And you're increasing
your priority in the queue
by wasting even more space.
So if everyone does Child Pays
for Parent, it's really bad.
Now every transaction
is going to take
two or three transactions.
And the dependency graphs
are kind of complex.
You can have--
I don't remember exactly how.
There are certain cases
where Child Pays for Parent
lowers the priority
of a transaction.
I didn't understand how.
But someone explained it to
me, and I'm like, oh, shoot,
that's bad.
Where someone else
spending an output can--
if there's a whole branch
of tons of different outputs
and tons of different
Child Pay for Parent,
there are certain
parts where, OK,
if someone makes a low fee
transaction, that can actually
lower the priority
of the parents.
I don't remember.
Anyway, so it's kind of
a mess, it's complex,
and it's also just
very inefficient.
OK, so another way which
seems obvious, why don't I
just double-spend it?
I made a transaction
with a low fee,
why doesn't my wallet
just say, look,
I'm going to replace
that transaction with one
with a higher fee?
And I just decrease the
change output amount.
That's simple, right?
[CHUCKLING]
Another problem-- the
default relay behavior
is to ignore double-spends.
And this is not just a
default that's for fun.
This is actually-- there's
good reasons for it.
So if you see a transaction
spending output A, output B,
and then you see
another transaction
over the wire, spending
one of those outputs
that you've already
seen, you will ignore it.
You won't ban-- won't get mad at
the person who sent it to you,
but you'll just ignore it.
Because you're
like, no, I already
saw a conflicting transaction.
So the default is,
first thing you see
is the thing you go with.
This is not a
consensus rule, right,
because we're not dealing with
anything that's in the blocks
yet.
But any ideas of why this is
an important rule to have?
What are some attacks
that you could perform?
If you just said,
yeah, anything--
I'm not going to stick with
the first-seen transaction.
I will update anytime
I see a new one.
I'll just go with the--
I'll go with the last-seen
transaction instead
of first-seen transaction.
What would be an attack that
would be enabled by that?
Any ideas?
You got to think adversarially.
I'm trying to
bring down Bitcoin.
If you change your code to last
seen instead of first seen,
how do I bring down the network?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
TADGE DRYJA: Right, yeah, I just
keep spending the same outputs,
100 times a second.
And they all have
the same fee rate.
I can just keep doing
that indefinitely,
and I just keep
flooding the network.
And everyone's like, oh, here's
this new one, oh, here's this--
total mess.
However, there is a way to
prevent that kind of flooding
attack, or at least
significantly mitigate
it, which is, OK, we'll relay
conflicting transactions,
but we require an
increase in the fee.
And the required increase is
equal to our minimum relay fee
of one Satoshi per byte.
So every time I
could say, OK, I'm
going to replace it because
it has a higher fee.
So now it's sort of
constantly incrementing.
You can't keep doing
that indefinitely.
Every time you want to
send a transaction out
to the network and use
everyone's network resources,
you are sort of potentially
paying something for it.
Yeah, you will continue
to ignore transactions
with same or lower fee.
Oh, I did the why.
Yeah, the why happened there.
Anyway, yeah, the DDoS attack
is make lots of transactions
with the same fee,
clog the network.
OK, so this seems simple, right?
We have replace by fee.
If you have a higher
transaction fee,
you replace the
transactions, wallets
implement it, no problem.
Well, people don't like it.
People said, no, we don't
like replace by fee.
This was a controversy
around 2015,
when a bunch of the
developers were like, yeah,
this seems reasonable,
let's put it in.
People said, no, this
hurts the security
of unconfirmed transactions.
And to some extent, they
do have a point, right?
If every node on
the network says
I'm going with my
first-seen transaction,
if there's a conflicting
transaction later, I ignore it.
That means it's hard
to double-spend,
even before it
gets into a block.
You spend-- you say, OK, I'm
going to send money to Alice,
and here's my change output.
And then you
replace it with, I'm
going to send money to Bob
instead, and my change output.
You can potentially make
it appear that someone's
going to get paid-- it
still says unconfirmed,
but they say, yeah, you
sent me a transaction,
it'll get confirmed
soon, and then
switch it out and try to
make it so that you pay it
back to yourself instead.
When everyone on the network
ignores those new transactions,
it gets harder.
You'd have to contact a
miner directly and say,
hey, I have this
transaction on the network,
here's a conflicting one, please
include it in your next block,
to double-spend, to
defraud this person.
The thing is, in practice,
it's not that hard to do this.
And so a lot of the
developers are like,
look, unconfirmed
transactions really
have no security with them.
And yeah, it might
seem like we're
reducing the security here,
but you really should not
depend on unconfirmed at all.
It's not in the blockchain.
There's no proof of work.
The whole point of the system
is to put the proof of work
to really get consensus.
And you cannot rely on
network-level consensus,
because there isn't any.
And yeah, so to
some extent, replace
by fee does make the
double-spends easier to do.
That's the point.
But the thing is, it's
not secure anyway.
So anyway, it's
also a UI issue--
should you even show
unconfirmed transactions?
Almost all of the wallets
do, even the SPV ones.
And the SPV ones have no
idea if it's even valid
or has a valid signature
since they can't even
check signatures.
Unconfirmed transactions
are not meaningless.
If you see it on the network,
and you're running a full node,
you see, yes, this
is a transaction
that could be confirmed.
They've provided
a valid signature.
Any miner can put this in.
There's no conflicts.
This can work.
If you're SPV and you see
an unconfirmed transaction,
you have no idea,
because you don't even
know if it's spending outputs
that exist because you
don't have a UTXO set.
You can't verify the signatures.
You don't even know what
the keys are supposed to be.
But most SPV wallets still
show unconfirmed transactions
because users want it.
They want to know.
And it's like, sometimes they'll
put it in, like, red text,
like, hey, it's unconfirmed,
or put a little question
mark next to it.
I would rather just
not show it at all.
I think it gives a
misleading sense to users.
But this is an issue, right?
Users are like, I want to know
if the sender has actually
signed and sent.
And then yeah, afterwards,
it gets in the block.
Yeah, now it's
confirmed, now it's safe.
But I want to know.
So SPV can sometimes connect
multiple nodes and ask.
But this is a
controversial thing
that people have argued about.
My personal opinion
is that security
is more important than UI
and usability in this case,
and you really should
not rely on anything that
has unconfirmed transactions.
And also, the RBF-- the
Replace By Fee policy
is not a network
consensus-level rule.
You don't know what
policy people have.
If people are running-- if
nodes are running "I just
stick with the
first-seen transaction,"
or "I replace with
incrementing fees,"
or "I replace no matter
what," or who knows,
"I'll go with three or four
updates and then I'll ignore."
You just don't know
what people are doing.
So the compromise
that's currently
in the Bitcoin software is
called opt-in replace by fee.
You flag a transaction by
changing the sequence number
in the input to not be FFFFF.
And then you indicate, hey,
I'm flagging my transaction
as this can be replaced
with an increasing fee.
It's kind of ugly in my opinion.
It's
Like-- it's not really opt-in.
You can't even opt out.
It's weird to say to people,
oh, yeah, you opt into RBF.
Because there's no
way to prevent it.
You can always
contact the miners,
or anyone can just run it.
And there's code
out there that's
a couple of lines
different that's
like, here's the full
RBF version of Bitcoin,
where it'll just
ignore this flag
and treat everything the same.
But we do now have the option--
so if you run a wallet,
and I believe that
the Bitcoin Core
Wallet, with the new
version last week
or last month, now, by default,
flags every transaction as
replace by fee, so that you
can then bump the fee later on.
And this is a much better
way to deal with fees.
Because then you're not stuck.
And then, to some
extent, you don't even
need to look at the
mempool and what
fees everyone else is paying.
You can just say, well, I can
also time-lock transactions,
and I can say, OK, well,
at the current block,
I'll pay one Satoshi per byte.
I'll also send out
a transaction where
it's not valid until
the next block,
and I pay two Satoshis per byte.
And then the block after
that, I'll pay four, and block
after that, I'll pay eight, or
whatever sort of fee schedule
you want.
And then the miners now
have the option to look
and say, well, two Satoshis
per byte is too little,
I'm not going to take it.
But then a block comes out--
OK, now it's four.
OK, I'll take that one.
And so that's a really nice
sort of fire-and-forget
from the user's wallet,
where I don't even
know what fee I should
pay, well, look,
I'll just keep incrementing it.
And hopefully it confirms
soon at a low rate.
As it takes longer and
longer, my rate goes up,
and eventually I'll get it in.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Are there any limits
to how many times you do that?
TADGE DRYJA: Not really.
OK, so one limit is you
cannot actually broadcast
the transaction that is
valid in a future block.
The network will ignore it.
It's a similar reason,
denial of service thing,
where, hey, here's a transaction
that's valid next week.
Well, why'd you
tell it to me today?
So you'd have to be
online to do that.
But your wallet can
do it automatically.
It can just do it
in the background.
And in practice, I
don't know any wallets
that do that right now.
The Core Wallet will
allow you to in the UI.
You sort of right-click
and you say, bump--
increase fee, and then it will
rebroadcast with an increased
fee.
OK, so yeah, it's a kind of a
mess, but it's getting there.
We're getting better at this.
Any questions before
we have a break?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So the one
[INAUDIBLE] they'd
pay [INAUDIBLE] their own
confirmation of transaction.
TADGE DRYJA: Well,
eventually they will, right?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
TADGE DRYJA: Will
they eventually?
AUDIENCE: Once it
gets the confirmation,
but normally they
accept transactions
without confirmation.
TADGE DRYJA: That's
silly anyway.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
TADGE DRYJA: OK, well
yeah, so some sites
will accept zero-conf
without RBF, but not with.
My thinking is they
shouldn't be accepting
zero-confirmation
transactions, regardless.
So whatever.
But yeah, and people--
there was a thing,
Peter Todd stole $10
from Coinbase a couple
years ago because he
was trying to prove a point.
It's so easy to double-spend
before it's in a block.
And all these different
sites are saying,
oh, yeah, here's a transaction
that's not confirmed yet,
but it will be soon.
And then they dispense
with the product.
And then I remember Peter
Todd was like, look,
I just got $10 from you
on Steam or whatever,
do you want it back?
And they didn't reply.
Because it's really
not that hard to
double-spend before
it's in a block.
The whole point of the
blockchain, all the mining,
is to prevent the double-spend.
OK, so the last part
is going to be about--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
TADGE DRYJA: Oh yeah,
I already said this.
One thing, though, is
further research is needed.
This has all been
changing in the last year.
If you had this talk a
year ago, it would sort of
be like, yeah, I guess you
could do replace by fee,
I guess fees could
work this way.
But we had never really had this
sustained, long fee ramp-up.
This hadn't happened.
This had never happened.
There had been cases where
sometimes blocks had been full,
but we'd never
seen this ramp-up.
It's also really
interesting how inelastic
it was, in that
people started paying
thousands of Satoshis per
byte, $20, $30 a transaction.
And people got mad about
it, but what was interesting
is people were paying.
If everyone refuses to pay
these rates, the rates go down.
But someone's paying that much.
But a lot of it is
exchanges and stuff.
OK, yeah, problems--
exchanges overpay.
Bitcoin D Wallets overpays.
Nobody cared for seven years.
It's sort of like it's
also, efficiency-wise,
in terms of your
transaction size,
it kind of reminds me of 2008
when everyone was driving
Hummers, and then gas
goes to like $4.00,
and then everyone gets a Prius.
That's happening now,
where it's like, OK,
let's batch our transactions.
Let's use compressed pub keys.
There's all sorts of
techniques to reduce
the size of your
transactions so more
can fit in the block which are
now still being implemented.
It's sort of after the fact.
It takes this, hey, you're
spending thousands of dollars
a day on this to really kick
people into action to write it.
I remember looking
into December, though,
at Coinbase's transactions
and being like,
you should hire-- you guys
are probably losing $1 million
a day.
I could fix this for you.
You should-- no?
OK.
[CHUCKLING]
But it's sort of
frustrating to see.
And probably, their
system is a huge mess
from so many different layers
and things on top of each other
that it's hard to fix.
But looking at--
Gemini also is an exchange.
They use uncompressed pub keys.
So the pub keys are 65
bytes instead of 33.
There's no advantage there.
It's just an extra 32 bytes.
Which they've probably spent, I
don't know, a couple hundred K
on just that weird
aspect of their software.
I don't know if they're
aware of this, even.
You might want to
be like, hey, guys,
you're spending too much money.
Because look, your transactions
are an extra 32 bytes
per input because of this.
But yeah, it's
interesting to see.
I've also paid.
I used to not pay.
Oh, one thing that used to
be the case, transactions
had priority, which
was based on the age
of the outputs multiplied by
the amount of the outputs.
That was a thing
until two years ago.
And it was great because
it meant if you were rich,
you didn't pay fees.
[CHUCKLING]
So if you had a
bunch of bitcoin,
it was kind of a maybe
not-so-great social idea
that, hey, if you have an output
that's got 100 coins in it,
you can make a
zero-fee transaction.
It actually worked from
a theoretical perspective
because it prevented spam.
Because the idea is, if
you have 100 coins, OK,
you can spend that every day
or something, with no fee.
If you have only
one coin, maybe have
to wait 100 days to be able
to spend it with no fee.
So there's this sort
of priority, age-based,
to limit the velocity
of these payments
based on how big they are.
They got rid of
that because it made
sense from a network
level, "let's protect
the network from spam" idea.
It did not make any
sense for the miners
to prioritize
these transactions.
I'm a miner, who cares if you
have a bunch of old outputs
that you haven't
spent in a long time.
It does nothing for me.
It does help the
network in general.
But so I was a
little disappointed,
because I don't
have a ton of coins,
but they're all really
old, so I could get away
without paying fees.
Long term though, this is
sort of an interesting thing
to look at.
I'm not sure that's--
oh, shoot, is that number right?
Wait, James, do you know?
Is it 210,000?
I think it is.
That number might be wrong.
I made a mental
note to confirm it.
I think it's right.
Anyway, the mining reward drops
in half, every four years,
approximately.
And eventually all
the coins are mined.
So it's dropped in half twice.
First it was 50 coins
a block, then 25,
and now it's 12 and 1/2.
In two years it's going
to be 6.25 or something.
So eventually all the coins
are gone, you mined them all.
That takes 100 years.
So everyone's like,
I'll be dead--
I'll be gone, you'll be gone.
But actually the rewards
become negligible a lot sooner
than you think.
In 20 years, there's
way less than a coin
in rewards, because it
keeps getting chopped
in half every four years.
so yeah, there's this
sort of long tail
where you've got like 50 years
of a couple Satoshis per block.
But it's negligible, right?
So the rewards going
to near zero actually
happens definitely within
our lifetimes, pretty soon.
And a lot of people
looking at Bitcoin
are sort of thinking
of it long term.
Bitcoin's only
worth a lot of money
now because people
think it's going
to be worth a lot of
money in 20 years, right?
If everyone knew it was going
to collapse in 10 years,
I think people
would lose interest.
So what are some weird
long-term problems?
OK, well if there's no new
coins to mine, why do you mine.
Well, the title of this piece.
However, it's not that simple.
There's a lot of problems
with the fees being
the only incentive, in that
TX fees are very variable.
Without a backlog, the fees tend
to go to pretty close to zero.
And if the fees are zero,
there's no reason to mine.
All the new coins
have been generated,
there's no fees in the
mempool, why am I running my--
maybe you have a megabyte
worth of zero-fee transactions
in the mempool.
But as a miner, why am
I spending electricity
to mine this?
I get nothing.
So the miners just turn off.
That would be what
they should do.
And you can see, yeah,
it's super variable.
Maybe miners are like,
oh, this is great,
we're making a ton of money.
And then here they're
like, I guess wrap it up,
close down the mining facility.
And that could be a problem,
even on much shorter time
scales, such as the time
scale of a single block.
So for example,
here's what you do.
You're a miner.
There's no fees in the mempool.
There's no reward.
There's no reason
to mine, right?
Turn off your chips,
and then turn them
back on once the mempool
starts filling up,
because it will eventually.
The idea is, OK, for the
next couple of minutes,
I'm just idling.
You could do that,
or you can be clever
and say, well, I've
got all these chips,
the opportunity cost,
a lot of it is CAPEX.
A lot of is the capital
expense of the chips
and not the electricity.
So if I'm just
turning off my chips,
that's a huge loss for me.
I want to run.
I don't want to run
with an empty mempool,
because I get nothing.
What should I do?
What's a fun attack?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Could you make
a bunch of transactions
where the fees are high,
and the new people will
leave when the fees are high?
TADGE DRYJA: Very good idea.
I'm pretty sure miners are
doing that, or were in November.
That doesn't help you--
that helps you sort
of medium-term, right?
In the very short
term, where there's
an empty mempool, what do I do?
There is another
attack you can do.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You can just
mine in empty blocks.
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah, but
I don't get any money.
You could, but that's
not a fun attack.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You could build up
a bunch of non-transactions.
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah, but
I want to get money.
I want to get paid, there's
nothing in the mempool,
where do I go?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Output to
another currency.
TADGE DRYJA: OK, so yes.
So in Bitcoin's
case, the algorithm--
well now there's Bitcoin
Cash, and so there's
sort of two chains that
share a single algorithm.
And in many alt coins, they
share either algorithms
or they're using a GPU,
which can be quickly switched
between different
mining algorithms.
In Bitcoin's case, though,
you're sort of stuck.
It's a big one, and
you're using Sha256.
So OK, good.
AUDIENCE: You could
mine off the previous--
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah, you
go back to the past.
You mine the past transactions.
OK, someone mined a bunch
of transactions here,
and they got two bitcoins.
Those are two bitcoins
I could've mined.
[CHUCKLING]
So that last block at a
couple of coins in fees.
I'm going to remine it.
I'm not getting anything if I
mine-- if I continue the chain
and make progress,
I get no money.
But if I try to snipe the
last guy's mining stuff,
I might be able
to take his money.
If you find two blocks
in a row, which happens,
you get all the fees.
So that's sort of an
optimal thing to do.
I've got all this
mining power, maybe
I turn it off because I'm
mostly OPEX instead of CAPEX.
But if I've got all
this mining power,
I'm going to use it no matter
what, the optimal thing to do
is try to take a
reorg the blockchain
and take the last person's fees.
So for example, instead
of sequentially building,
you fight over it.
So here's this blockchain.
OK, Alice got two, Bob
got three, Carol got two,
Dave got one.
These are fees within the block.
And now the current
mempool, it's zero.
Dave got it.
Dave swept it.
It was sort of declining,
sort of going up.
Dave completely
emptied the mempool.
There's nothing in there.
And there's no new
coins coming out.
So I'm what, Eve,
I'm the attacker.
Eve is always the
bad person, right?
So what's also even better, I
say, OK, I'm going to build--
I'm going to try
to reorg out Carol.
I can take all the fees here.
I can take the two bitcoins
here and the one bitcoin here,
and I can mine it
into this block.
This block is not
valid yet, right?
This is higher.
But I might build
another block here.
And then I might build
And by now there
might be some coins.
So now I get four coins.
I could have mined here
and gotten nothing.
If this happens and I pull
it off, "puh-toom," OK,
Carol and Dave's
coins are now mine.
So this is a--
And to some extent,
you might think, well,
whatever, it's a little
messy, but this is not
the worst thing in the world.
You still make progress.
It's actually really bad.
Because you're now trading
this sort of memoryless process
where everyone's competing
on a level playing ground
where whoever can mine fastest
is always going to win here.
So now if you're a miner that's
twice as big as the next guy,
you're always going to be
able to do this-- not always,
there's still some--
but this really
reduces the variance
and really incentivizes
the miners to consolidate.
And you're going to
end up with a monopoly
in this kind of a scenario,
because small players will just
always get a reorged out.
Yeah, so the question--
is this an attack?
It seems like they're just
trying to get paid, right?
The whole idea is you're
not trusting the miners.
You're just assuming
that they're acting
in their economic interests.
To some extent, you could say,
well, if they keep doing this,
they reduce the
utility of Bitcoin,
and so it's bad
for their holdings.
Yeah, maybe, but it
looks dangerous, right?
However, this isn't a problem.
We don't see this problem today.
There have actually been several
cases where we should have,
where it would have been
optimal for the miners.
So someone made a fee
that was like 1,000--
no, it was 400
bitcoins or something.
They just screwed up.
They made a
transaction, and they
were spending like
1,000 bitcoins
and they only sent like
600 out or something.
So the fee was 400
bitcoins, which is like,
hey, that's way
more than a block.
That's millions of dollars.
It wasn't when it was
millions of dollars,
but it's still a ton of money.
And the miners, if
they were rational,
they should have
all just stopped
and all tried to fight
each other over that one
block and that one
transaction, because it's
so much more valuable than
progressing the chain.
However, they didn't,
because they were just
running their software.
They weren't anticipating
this kind of thing.
However, if this becomes,
long term, the general state
of the network, they'll
definitely anticipate it,
and they'll write the
software to do this.
So it's not a problem
when there's low reward
variance from block to block.
If every block-- if the
next block coming out
has about the same
fees as the last one,
then you just keep
building on it
and you're not trying to snipe
other people in the past.
But that means there's
going to be a backlog.
You need this really big
mempool with a large backlog
of transactions
to ensure that you
have low variance in the rewards
and to ensure that, long term,
you've got a stable system.
So this is tricky.
This is a hard problem.
Because you've already got
these sort of scalability
balances in Bitcoin.
One of them is related
to your hardware.
So if you say, OK, we're going
to make the block size really
small, we're going to make
the block size 10 kilobytes,
so you can only have a few
transactions every 10 minutes,
if it's too small,
then very few people
can actually use Bitcoin.
There's just not that many
transactions a second.
Most people will have
something like Coinbase,
where someone else holds
the coins for them.
That's no fun.
The point is to
have your own UTXO,
so really be in control
of your own money
and have your own private keys.
However, if the
blocks are too large,
then not many people can run it.
If the blocks are
a gigabyte each
and you've got these
petabyte-sized blockchains,
I can't run that.
I need a data center.
And then you can't really
verify and validate
that the system is operating
the way you think it will.
You're just going to
have to trust, again,
some kind of big institution
to do it for you.
So they both sort of
turn into the same thing
when you're at the extremes.
If it's too small, well, I
can't really own my own coins,
I got to have someone
else do it for me.
If it's too large, I guess I
can own my own private keys,
but I have no idea
if they're actually--
if there's an actual
transaction in the blockchain
because I can't download it.
So these are sort of
balances based on hardware.
And we're thinking, well, as
computers get more powerful
and networks get more
powerful, we can sort of
get into the larger side
and people will still
be able to run it.
And we have seen that.
So like with SegWit,
the block size
has been increased
through software.
So it now takes a bit more
space and more network traffic
to use.
However, the long-term
fee sniping thing,
it's not hardware related.
Even if you had
perfect computers that
were sort of like, oh,
this network can send
any amount of data instantly,
we've got unlimited drive
space, these are computronium--
that's a thing, right, the
theoretical maximum computer.
So even if you have
this amazing computer
and the hardware limits
are not a limit at all,
you still have to
balance the block size.
Because if you make your
block size too large,
you're going to have that
problem long term, where
there's no real fee market
because there's no competition
to get into the blocks.
And so the whole system kinds
of halts, and then you've
got the largest miner
just keep winning.
So this is a mess.
There's a paper.
What's it called?
Like, Bitcoin Is Not Stable
Without a Fee or something.
It's Princeton guys, right?
"On the Instability of Bitcoin
Without the Block Reward."
And to be fair--
yeah, these are Princeton guys.
To be fair-- and they
write about this issue.
But it's a little weird,
because one of their assumptions
is that--
mining strategy simulator.
Anyway, one of their assumptions
is that every miner completely
wipes out the mempool
at every block.
And it's like, wait,
that assumption--
given that assumption, yes,
you can show that it's unstable
and there's all these problems,
like I was sort of showing.
But that assumption
is a huge assumption.
And a lot of the people
working on Bitcoin
are like, no, you can't
make that assumption.
Because we're aware that there's
these instability problems,
and the solution, to the extent
that it's a solution, is always
have a backlog.
There's a really big
demand for transactions,
and there's not
enough space, and so
people have to compete
based on their fees.
In that case, you can have
a stable system, long term,
where the miners get paid.
But without it,
these guys show it.
And so yeah, it's true,
but it's sort of weird
because one of
their assumptions is
that there are no fees,
long term, essentially.
So yeah, this is a weird issue,
and it's also how, timing-wise,
do we need to worry
about this now?
Maybe we can just punt
the problem for a decade
and try to get lots of adoption,
lots of people using Bitcoin,
and we'll figure it out once
it's really well established.
I don't think that works.
I think it's harder and
harder to change these systems
as more people use it.
So maybe we're stuck.
And it's almost certain that
one megabyte or four megabytes
is not the optimal size.
We have no idea what the
optimal size is, right?
Long term-- because
also, long term,
how many people are
going to using this,
and for what, and for
what kind of transactions?
So it's definitely
an open problem.
Yeah, so we're sort of
at the dawn of the fees.
A year ago, we didn't
have all these things.
We're starting to
understand the fee markets
and see how it works.
What's interesting is
that the elasticity
seems like people really want
their transactions in when
they want them in, which
I guess can make sense.
If the price of Bitcoin
spikes to $18,000,
and you're like, I want to
sell one, it's going to crash,
and you're like, yeah,
I'll pay $50 to move it,
to sell to someone, because
I'm selling millions of dollars
worth.
And so it seems
really inelastic.
You also have people,
companies, wasting millions
of dollars on fees that you can
just be like, why'd you do--
oh, OK.
You're wasting on
space, wasting on fees.
It is a fun research area.
And it's definitely research.
And so I'm like, yeah,
I hope this works.
We don't really know, long term,
if this whole system is stable
and works.
I think it can.
But it's not something to base
the global economy on just yet,
because we're not quite sure
it all really works long term,
but we think it does.
OK, any questions about this
sort of long-range attack
stuff?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: What's the case
with a bunch alt coins points
that don't have full members?
TADGE DRYJA: Alt coins?
AUDIENCE: The rest of
the cryptocurrency space
that has sparse mempools.
TADGE DRYJA: They
generally don't have fees,
or the fees are enforced--
you can enforce a fee.
You can say, hey, the consensus
rule of this system is that
every transaction has to have
a 50-Satoshis-per-byte fee.
There's problems with
that, because then you
can have out-of-band
fees where, if you
try to make it a consensus
rule, it doesn't really work.
It's sort of like price
controls, where you can say,
hey, you have to sell
milk for $2 a gallon.
And it's like, well, that's
not what the market says.
So people can go out of band.
And then they're saying,
OK, the consensus rule
is I have to pay this fee, but
really, how about you give me
some of it back?
Or-- so generally
the rules they put
in are minimum
fees, which you can
try to work around that way.
But in general, most of
the other alt coins--
with the exception of
Ethereum, Ethereum definitely
has similar issues--
but most of the alt
coins have a block size
or a network capacity
that exceeds their uses.
So there isn't
really competition
to get into the next block.
Ethereum, though,
similar to Bitcoin, has--
well, I don't-- where did it go?
This kind of thing.
I don't know, if you
graphed Ethereum,
it probably wouldn't
look quite the same.
But there are also
times in Ethereum
where the fees skyrocket.
A lot of times
with ICOs, everyone
wants to get in their
bids really quick,
and so the network will get
super congested for a day,
and no one can use it for
anything-- for normal uses.
So Ethereum also
has this problem.
It's not quite the same in
that it's not a block size,
it's a gas per
block kind of thing,
so how much computation
or storage it's using.
But in practice it's
a similar thing.
So yeah, those are
sort of the only two
that I'm aware of that really
have hit this issue so far.
Any other questions about
this, the long term?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Could you
comment on blockchains
that have no transaction fee,
particularly blockchains that
are designed for
things like IoT,
and which pay to be able
to handle microtransactions
and transactions at face
value without any fee.
TADGE DRYJA: Should I
take advice from counsel
before commenting on this?
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, so you could Google--
there's one, I
don't know if you're
talking about it
specifically-- there's
one called Iota that we
looked at last summer.
My mom tells me, if you don't
have anything nice to say,
don't say anything.
But we did say quite
a bit in our report.
That one specifically,
I don't think
it really works that well.
Actually, they have a fee,
they just pretend they don't.
But they very much have a fee.
So in Iota's case,
they say, you have
to do work on your transaction.
You have to mine
your transaction.
And they say that's not a fee.
Well, OK, it's on a fee you're
paying to some other miner,
but you're still doing work.
That has a cost.
You can say it's
a cost, not a fee.
I don't know.
But it feels like saying, hey,
this refrigerator doesn't need
electricity to run, it's just
got a hand crank in the back
that you have to--
yeah, OK, I don't
have to plug it in,
but I still have
to do all the work.
So it's an anti-spam measure
which you have to do work on.
So it's the same new thing.
But there are some that
have no fee whatsoever,
and they're very
susceptible to spamming.
If there's no fee, what stops
me from just sending out
a bazillion
transactions and having
everyone else store them?
AUDIENCE: Generally
well MANO is one of them
that claims to be instant
no fees, et cetera.
But what that means
is, to get around that,
they've made it so that you
don't need global consensus--
until you do need global
consensus, at which point
you do proof of state
and [INAUDIBLE]..
But since there
are no fees, it's
free to just calls for
state to happen every round,
[INAUDIBLE] a bunch of
conflicting transactions.
TADGE DRYJA: Huh.
Yeah, there's a lot of really
smart people, way smarter
than me, working
on these things.
And it's a hard
problem, and they seem
to think it's a hard problem.
So I'm very skeptical
when someone, especially
with a financial interest
in getting me to believe
that they've solved
this problem,
says, hey, I've solved
the problem, zero fees,
infinite scalability.
I'm just very skeptical
when I see that.
Because, OK, what did you do?
Like, we've been
looking at this.
Maybe there's something there.
But I haven't seen any
really great stuff.
There's Lightning Network, which
I'll talk about in a few weeks,
and I think that's pretty cool,
and I sort of work on that.
There's other different
ways to do this.
But in general, there's
got to be a cost.
There's no free lunch.
And you're going to have to--
if you're requiring other
people to store a lot of data
and process it, there's got to
be some kind of limit there.